good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director here at long now as
many of you know we do a long short a
short movie that exemplifies long-term
thinking before a lot of these seminars
tonight's was suggested by someone in
house Laura welter and the folks at the
mirror project were very nice to give us
permission to to run it it's very much a
present movie but I think it gives a
good piece of context for Laura's talk
tonight and well she's can be talking a
lot about that the deep past of
California I think it's always good to
be reminded of how amazing its present
is and it's a basically a time lapse
from the beginning and and to the end of
the mirror trail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now foundation now I should say that
pour ecology ecology is an observational
science it wants to be a predictive
science and it has great theory envy of
other Sciences like physics and
chemistry and so on and we've got Darwin
that's as good a theory as you get but
every so often somebody says oh I know
how it all works and so I was taught in
the 1950s at Stanford that there's this
thing called succession which led to a
wonderful thing called a climax
community so you know Lakewood grass
over and gradually become forests and
then there would be a set of trees and
that would be it and preservers would
try to identify climax and then protect
it forever climax went away there's a
few nostalgic preservers who
occasionally refer to it but it turns
out that things don't hold still
in ecology not in any form and sad to
say community went away turns out that
these various species deal very
intimately with one another and then
things change and they move on some
North some South someway some new ones
arrive and it's not a community anymore
that we refer to it as an assemblage not
quite as romantic where the romance is I
think in ecology is way longer than the
four-year studies that almost all
ecology gets out of people going through
their graduate program ecology is this
thing which happens over centuries
millennia and more and the ecologist and
illustrator who's really paid attention
to that is here tonight or Cunningham
[Applause]
thanks for coming to this talk which is
about a project which I've been working
on for the past 20 years maybe longer
maybe 30 years it was a project even
when I was a kid I would walk around in
the East Bay where I grew up I grew up
just north of Berkeley and I would
wonder what was the past like what was
my house like specifically because I
grew up in an area with suburbs and
roads and cars and looking over the city
and even as a kid I wanted to know what
was that piece of ground like before the
house so I would imagine walking in a
grassland with Oaks and seen a game
trail which grasses or even coming upon
a coast live oak that had a big rub on
the trunk because apparently grizzly
bears like to rub their backs upon
boulders and tree trunks
so childhood daydreams led to
researching in about the 80s an idea for
a book this was a an idea that went back
something like 20 or 30 years that I
wanted to publish a book and research
what the bay area and maybe more of
California what it was like a thousand
years ago and there's a lot of really
good books out there that have the
before and after the city like the
photographs of San Francisco then and
now that was an inspiration but nobody
had gone beyond the photographs and
tried to do paintings of what the area
looked like before cameras so I I'm a
self-taught artist really got into
studying the oil paintings of say the
Hudson School Hudson River School which
is some of the greatest artists
naturalist in the 1800s even 1700s came
from Europe and they went West with some
of the scientific explorers and Albert
Bierstadt is one Church William Keith
and they had their little oil painting
and they would sketch things like
Yosemite Valley the Rockies and so I
tried to get a feel of what if I had my
oil sketch kit and I went back a
thousand years into California and was
just wandering around this grand
landscape and just trying to take sketch
notes and paint here and there scenes
that I saw so that was sort of the goal
I had in mind was to produce a book that
had that feel of an exploration of the
past so these are little oil paintings
sketches they're mostly miniatures a lot
of them are oil on paper because that's
what a lot of these 1800 oil painters
would do they'd have very nice cotton
rag paper treated stuff a bunch and a
bag put it on a mule and have their
paint sets and just whip out these
little oil sketches so when I was a kid
I would go to this Creek its until Dan
Regional Park in the East Bay Wildcat
Creek and I would cross the creek at the
same spot for weekends after school
sometimes and I began to see changes
going across this Creek in the same
place there's a little bridge that were
greater than changes that you'd see over
a year they were there are changes that
I began to see over the course of 10 15
years that were different than just
summer and winter or the wet season in
the dry season
I saw it changes that you needed to
observe the same place for decades to
actually see that change happening for
example the oil painting on the top
right is a drought year when Wildcat
Creek didn't flow at all and I wondered
as a kid what happened to the fish on
the lower part the lower right if people
were living in California during 1998-99
we had a huge El Nino event and it
ranged that January harder than I'd ever
seen Wildcat Creek became a monstrous
flood and took out the bridge that I had
Rost so many times as a kid was just a
monstrous mudflow destroyed roads took
out trees and then after the flood
waters subsided I crossed the creek and
noticed that the creek bed had gone down
two feet just overnight gouge down there
change was sudden so here's the street I
grew up just in the Richmond Berkeley
Hills looking west towards Mount Tam
just a photograph I took long ago and I
tried to imagine what my neighborhood
looked like before this scene so doing
some research I painted this oil
painting this is the East Bay with
native grasslands and you can see the
Golden Gate without the bridge in San
Francisco in this upper left
I would imagine walking on these grassy
Ridge tops with sea breezes waving
purple Deedle grass stems and a sunset
in a summer evening and if I went down
to the Albany mud flats I might see this
this is a painting actually based on
there's a historical report at Monterey
Bay in the 1800's where there's a
beached whale and a bunch of Grizzlies
were feeding on it and it actually
ripped a hole into the whale and we're
going inside of it now I must admit this
scene was a little harder to reconstruct
this took a long time a lot of
imagination
this is Knob Hill looking east you can
barely see the Bay Bridge there and it
was interesting just a couple of weeks
ago I was walking on O'Farrell Street
and I don't know what they're doing
putting in a subway or something but
they had ripped a giant hole and you
could see some of the sand under the
street some of the old ancient San
Francisco and then I tried to get it in
we closed but there is some sort of
brickwork was this like an old Street of
bricks from a century ago under
o'farrell Street I don't know but
there's always clues around to the
ancient past so putting together some
research this is the scene I came up
with this is before and this is 200
years ago my theory of what the same
spot looked like so Coit Tower it would
be on that hill to the right Yerba Buena
Island Market Street in downtown would
be on that Bay which has since been land
filled and of course skyscrapers
towering above but the scene has things
like blue blossom lilac a type of
ceanothus shrub which is flowering
purple coyote brush California sagebrush
a lot of native bunch grasses and you
can see a fallen elk antler
there are tule elk roaming these hills
in the past
moving to the East Bay Oakland this is
Lake Merritt just some photographs I
took and pieced together
what did this look like in the past Lake
Merritt was a saltwater inlet of the bay
and of course Oakland named for all the
coasts live oaks and this is where I
grew up
El Cerrito Plaza saw a lot of changes
from a big-box store department store to
the present Barnes & Noble all the
different chains so it's a big parking
lot now and that's Albany Hill covered
with blue gum eucalyptus which were
imported from Australia decades ago in a
futile attempt to grow wood for building
but the the eucalyptus turned out to be
really brittle not very good for much
but you could use clues to try to get an
idea of what this scene looked like from
things such as this this is called a dis
a no it's a map hand-drawn map from the
Mex
in period of California which was 1821
to 1846 and it was hand-drawn to define
a land grant for a Rancho and they were
really useful because they would put in
the groves of trees they would draw in
creeks they would sometimes put in
individual dotted redwoods here and
there so this is actually of El Cerrito
it shows Albany hill and the creeks that
still flows under El Cerrito Plaza the
original Bayshore so here's that scene
of El Cerrito Plaza as I imagine it a
thousand years ago grizzly is feeding on
fallen acorns under an oak the bay
beyond
Albany Hill was a grassland so what I
try to do I wanted to do this for every
city in California but that turned out
to be just the publisher said no we got
to stop it you can go on forever but I
would try to go to different places this
was the mission at Santa Barbara and
take photos get a nice scene and then
try to research that exact piece of land
and try to reconstruct what it looked
like in the past so yeah this is my oil
painting on top and you can see the
ridge line is the same same perspective
and view this was a little easier to
reconstruct because of course the
Spanish missionaries came right to that
spot and tried to describe it and they
mentioned scattered oaks a lot of grass
a lot of it was burned off by Indians
and there were also tall grasses that
were the size of a man and a horse they
came up to the saddle horn and they of
course didn't really say what species of
grass which doesn't help us today but
when you go north of Santa Barbara along
a similar stretch of coastline there are
these big tall grasses and they're
native there are a type of giant wild
rye and so I decided that might have
been what he was seen so I put those the
big brownish bunches into the painting
going inland
this is Friant Dam on the San Joaquin
River today near Fresno long ago it was
a free-flowing River of course with
salmon runs and then going into Southern
California this is just north of
Hollywood San Fernando Valley and I
would try to pick a scene that at least
had maybe a tiny remnant of something I
could go hiked up into in these hills
and get some idea of what plants or
birds were still living in that area so
in the past this scene might have looked
like this giant Grizzlies roaming the
hills so then California was interesting
because it had the largest bears in the
lower 48 they were the size of Alaskan
brown bears one was shot and it's
hearsay but it weighed 2,200 pounds a
grizzly that weighed a ton
they were all over Southern California
they're all over San Francisco a little
smaller up here but I've been doing
these talks around Californian couple of
about a month ago I did a talk in San
Fernando Valley and it's really great to
meet people who have new information
they can add to the theory my painting
image theory of what the past looked
like and this fellow came up and he said
well my grandmother was born in San
Fernando Valley and she used to paint
what it looked like and you are right it
didn't have any trees all of her
paintings just show this vast grassland
covered with wild flowers so I thought
great that's a nice confirmation that
this painting is has some evidence to
back it up
so the techniques I use to reconstruct
these scenes or a lot of fieldwork just
hiking around California and taking
notes of what I see just being an
old-fashioned naturalist a lot of
library research that was
really important there's a lot of good
history books and descriptions old
photographs paintings and museums
historic maps and even their vacant lots
this is my sister and I walking around
El Cerrito trying to get some idea for
the painting reconstructing El Cerrito
Plaza and we found a native grass right
on the strip along a street and I don't
think anyone planted it it wasn't just
an empty lot had not been built the
other photograph is of a creek that had
never been cemented over just flowing
right by houses a clue to the past so I
take all of this evidence and research
back to my studio and I begin a painting
with a little thumbnail sketch just a
little idea sketch scribbled quickly on
paper and then the next stage I take it
to a more detailed pencil sketch this
happens to be a scene of the past of a
Maya village with the Sacramento River
flowing into the Delta the North Delta
and this is a stage which is useful to
send or email these images to experts
and try to get some feedback and one
anthropologist told me well the Maidu
village probably had different types of
architecture in their houses it was more
varied than you made it so the next
stage I'll add color and you can see I
varied the the huts and then I sometimes
take these into a large oil painting
full size like an oil on pan or canvas
but for the purposes of this book
they're mostly small such as this
painting of a grizzly long ago this is
in the South Coast range so the the
Golden Bear the Grizzly that was quite a
fascinating topic to think that these
Grizzlies were roaming about right
around San Francisco the East Bay
apparently abundantly and it would have
been quite a different
time to live in the state and try to be
a hiker or any sort of recreationist so
to get an idea of that I spent a lot of
time in Yellowstone National Park
because that was a fairly safe and easy
place to go see wild Grizzlies so these
are some sketches from my sketchbook but
it's amazing how many things are named
after Grizzlies today in the state
there's grizzly Peaks Bear Creek there's
even a Mount Baldy in Southern
California and that has a story behind
it there is apparently a grizzled old
bear that had been in a fight and
another bear had ripped off the fur on
top of his head so they they often had
names for these Grizzlies and the 1800s
oh that was Baldy and he often hung out
on this peak so there's a lot of history
you can pick up even from place names
and in my research is trying to
reconstruct what California Grizzlies
were like I discovered that they ate a
very wide variety of foods they were big
enough to chase down and kill a bull elk
which is the size of a horse they like
to use their claws to dig up ground
squirrels and Gophers and also the bulbs
of wild onion but they ate a huge
variety of plants from manzanita berries
to clover to California blackberry and
of course they also like to eat salmon
the abundant salmon and trout that were
in our rivers this is a painting of
Grizzlies feeding on salmon and the
Sacramento River once a common scene you
can see the long claws that these
Grizzlies used to dig that might have
had a real influence on the grasslands
in the past all this tilling and routing
by Grizzlies but as we know the Grizzly
is no more in the state I lived briefly
in a town just near Watsonville called
coral Ito's and I learned that that
actually was named for the bear and
bullfights that often happened in
Carlitos which means little Corral the
bull pen so the last grizzly in
California was shot in 1922 in Fresno
County however one was seen in Sequoia
National Park in 1924 so there's a
couple of other contenders around the
state for the last grizzly there's also
some sightings in the Los Padres
National Forest east of Santa Barbara
and then they were gone some of the
other animals that were very common all
over California Central in Northern
California including San Francisco where
elk we had to Li L kir we had very large
dark-colored Roosevelt elk up in the
Redwood zone and we even had the big
antlered Rocky Mountain Elk in the
sagebrush country of northeastern
California but going to Yellowstone was
really interesting to see how grizzly is
an elk interacted because I was always
interested in how the whole ecosystem
might have appeared in California so I
went to Yellowstone one spring and this
sketch on the upper right shows cow elk
had just dropped their calves and I
learned something that spring that
Grizzlies really like to eat calves
newborns an easy target but the calves
are born without any sort of odor
whatsoever not even a dog can sniff them
out so these cow elk were they knew
where the calf was hidden but the
grizzly walked right by it
so these are scenes that were probably
played over and over again in our own
state so there's a lot of records of
where elk were found and you can get a
pretty good idea of historically the
range of elk in California here's an oil
painting of tule elk
in a blue oak savanna in the hills east
of San Jose
in our state capital excellent
l Cabot at in the past this is how it
might have appeared hundreds of years
ago some people might think that's an
improvement
but this is a valley oak savannah with
herds of elk and antelope grazing on
native bunch grasses the other hoofed
animal that was very common all over
California abundant including San
Francisco were pronghorn antelope this
is a oil painting of antelope in the
Mojave Desert at sunset and this project
I sometimes wish it could have just been
a website because then I could keep
updating it a book is very final in ways
and I have to leave it go and keep
hearing stories of how we are restoring
in California and a friend who is a
biologist just told me a couple of weeks
ago that they're going to reintroduce
desert pronghorn antelope to south of
Joshua Tree National Park so for the
first time in more than a hundred years
we'll have this scene again they are
native to California still they still
exist in the northeast part of the state
and there are a couple of places around
the Bay Area near the Bay Area where you
can actually try to go see antelope um
there's a place called mines Road which
is south of Livermore where private
ranchers have allowed the Department of
Fish and Game to reintroduce antelope
and I've tried many times to drive on
this road and find them but never
succeeded so they're almost in the Bay
Area and there are other animals
predators of course that were preying on
all these elk and antelope and deer
which are sometimes surprising to learn
were in California wolves were reported
all over they were not common this is a
big oil painting 40 by 60 oil painting
of a white wolf in
now Yosemite National Park and once
again going to Yellowstone was really
good to see the reintroduced wolf pack
that was there interacting with elk
Grizzlies antelope you could get an idea
of this entire ecosystem that might have
existed in California so we would have
wolf and bear watching parties people
from England and all over these states
and we'd huddle together on the side of
the road next to our cars because
they're all these bears roaming about
and we'd have spotting scopes and you'd
get up at dawn before dawn and just scan
with binoculars in your spotting scope
and then you'd hear in the early morning
the howl of a lone wolf and then we were
lucky enough to get this one one morning
oh just a one lone wolf came out onto a
meadow and caught a meadow mouse a
little vole and just played with it for
hours didn't eat it just tossed it up in
the air like a dog but even stranger in
California we had native Jaguars and
there are reports of Jaguars from San
Diego all the way up to San Francisco so
apparently in the oak woodlands along
the coast range all the way to here
there were Jaguars hunting deer and
other animals and these dense woodlands
they also went up the Colorado River
from Mexico almost to Las Vegas so this
is a painting of desert Jaguars
along the Colorado River and of course
California condors one of our great
state legacies all over the state in the
past and I was lucky enough in the 1980s
to go sketch and watch for weeks on end
some of the last wild condors back in
the 80s there was something like eight
or nine left in the wild
in the whole world and the biologists
had decided that because they were
getting lead poisoning from eating the
carcasses that hunters had not been able
to catch deer wood
shot with lead bullets and then run into
the brush and die and the hunter
couldn't find them and then these
condors were eating them but they were
getting lead poisoning from the bullets
so a decision was made to net all of
these condors take them into the
captivity and various zoos captive breed
them and then released them but it was
sort of a sad period because in about
1985 we thought well this is it this
they're gonna catch all the last wild
condors and will they ever be released
again will this breeding program work so
I went down there and again just you
have to have a lot of patience to write
this book spent hours with a spotting
scope and usually we would see nothing
for days and then suddenly we'd see a
little black spot come over the hills
and it was a huge Condor and a bunch of
them would land next to this little calf
carcass that the biologist had planted
and they actually the biologist would
hide in a hole in the ground and have an
explosive trigger that would fire a net
over the Condor that's how they caught
them but meanwhile they were very
interesting to observe so I
reconstructed a scene long ago based on
these observations when condors were
still common but I noticed that when you
watch documentaries about African
animals and you see all the African
vultures coming on a carcass and they're
fighting and squabbling this wasn't
happening with the California condors
what we saw they they seemed to have a
pecking order a dominance hierarchy
where one or two condors would feed for
hours and all the other condors would
have to wait and the Golden Eagles would
have to wait their turn to and these
Eagles are big giant talons but they
were a little bit smaller than the
condors and one time this eagle came
down tried to sneak up to the carcass
and a giant Condor came landed and
opened its huge black and white wings
and the golden eagle ran downhill scared
an oil painting of what may happen soon
in the future bald eagles and California
condors feeding on salmon in a redwood
stream so the good news is the condors
are doing very well the captive breeding
program worked and they're being
reintroduced to places like pinnacles
and one this year came probably up from
pinnacles all the way to Mount Hamilton
which is technically the Bay Area so
Celt wild California condors that have
been successfully bred are inching their
way up to our area and then of course
there is the salmon that all these
Grizzlies and condors fed on in the past
this is Carquinez Strait long ago
without the bridges the ships and I used
to think sitting on this hillside
looking down at the gap in the Coast
Range where the combined flows of the
Sacramento and San Joaquin pour through
into the bay what was it like at certain
times of year when a million four foot
long fish crowded through that straight
up hundreds of miles of streams and
rivers all through the Sierra it must
have been amazing
most of those salmon were the chinook
salmon that get really big they were our
most abundant large salmon in California
into the main main stem rivers of the
sacramento-san Joaquin all up into small
streams in this era these are the
spawning colors they're pretty dark
those are eggs I used to work for a
California Department of Fish and Game
and I learned a couple of the secret
places where you can still see these
chinook salmon spawning so this is an
oil painting of a tributary off the
Smith River in December near Oregon and
the dark forms painted there are the big
salmon like three feet four foot
and they're going under these Rapids and
using their tail to make what's called a
red which is a big scoop in the gravel
and then they lay their eggs the other
common salmon that we had in California
was the coho this is a male and it's
spawning colors they just get brilliant
red and these were more of the coastal
salmon in a small creeks and streams
from Oregon all the way down to nearly
Santa Barbara and maybe even south of
that in the past so this is a painting
of a mother grizzly and Cubs coming to
feed on the spawned out Cohoes and it's
based on an area that you can still see
this scene - the Bears
it's lag Anita's Creek in Marin County
this is one of the few places that the
coho still run up and they may be
running right now because whenever rains
come and and increase the flow that's
when they go up so I learned that there
of course we've had kind of a problem
maintaining the huge abundance of these
millions of salmon of the past
they're quite declined now and there's
various reasons for that but one of them
I learned was the quality of their
spawning habitat these crystal-clear
streams with the gravel sometimes the
gravel will get what's called embedded
with silt and on the right there that
illustrates how this gravel is very
important it has to have oxygenated
water flowing through it just like when
you put a you have a fish tank and you
have your bubbler they need really clean
clear oxygenated water flowing through
that gravel to give oxygen to the eggs
and the baby fish that then live in that
gravel so historically what's happened
in the 1800s and 1900s is some episodes
of clear-cutting
just allowed huge amounts of erosion to
pour all the silt into these salmon
streams and that clogged up a lot of the
gravel but even today
we have some poor management of a dirt
road where say they'll put in a under
pipe that's not big enough and it will
just get clogged with debris and then
eroded away but what was very hopeful
about all this is what people are doing
to restore these streams and bring the
salmon back
I traveled up to the Klamath River in
Northern California and talked with a
group of native tribes local people
residents government agencies and they
were all working together to restore the
Klamath River to bring back steelhead
trout and salmon but what they told me
was you don't start with the fish you
don't even start with the river you go
up to these ridge tops on top of the
canyon ridges in the mountains and
that's where you start and you try to
imitate how elk would have grazed a
bunch grassland so that it wouldn't be
over grazed like we sometimes do now so
that these grasses could grow deep roots
and you could even have cattle but you
had to manage them where the grasses
would grow into the soil and prevent
siltation and erosion and you had to
manage the forest so that nutrients
would fall off these great trees and
then flow into the water and it would
provide nutrients grow insects and fish
food so it's very interesting to see
this holistic view of people saying well
we're going to restore this entire
watershed and then we'll just
automatically get salmon back so in the
book I also talk about our very amazing
coasts and seas shorelines this is the
Hayward Fremont Bay Bay Shore long ago
coyotes prowling on marshes and
white-fronted geese
in San Francisco Bay had and some of the
coasts the protected Bay's on the coast
had these huge shoals and schools of
small fish like anchovy and herring and
sardines and it would attract whales and
sea lions and fur seals feeding on this
and I used to think that this was a
thing of the past but last February my
sister who lives in Richmond saw
something that I thought was truly
amazing and it was just because she was
walking on the bay trail it was in
February and she saw a thousand seagulls
covering the water the shallow bay shore
waters and they were jumping and diving
into the water and just flying and
making a quite a racket calling and she
couldn't figure out why these goals were
here she'd never seen that many seagulls
but fortunately a fisherman came by and
said you are lucky enough to be here on
the one or two days where the herring
are running so they have this they black
in the water these heron come and they
apparently still come to the the East
Bay the San Francisco Bay they lay their
eggs which get attached to little
seaweed under water and then there's
just a feeding frenzy of birds but
apparently they had had an unusually
good herring run this February so she
was lucky to see that but they were also
stranger animals that inhabited our
coasts this is the Steller's sea cow
which bones have been found in Monterey
Bay 18,000 years ago it was 35 feet long
and weighed 10 tons and apparently
floated around and just on the surface
and ate kelp
now since 18,000 years ago the climate
changed and it really likes cold water
so it's range shrank up into around the
Alaskan islands that area so it was only
found in Alaska and it was discovered to
science in the year 1741
and then went extinct in 1768 it was
eaten by sailors there's some other
strange birds that were recorded in
California and there's some real
mysteries that I haven't been able to
figure out this one is the it's called
the gog because that's the the sound it
made it's also called a giant petrel and
had an 8 foot wingspan and was recorded
in the 1800's again in Monterey Bay
because there's just a lot of people
there and it would float around the bay
picking at whale blubber from some of
these whaling operations at went on
today it's only found in the southern
hemisphere it only breeds around
Antarctica and it is in the entire last
150 years never been cited in the entire
northern hemisphere why that's quite a
mystery why it was found in Monterey Bay
but there are even stranger animals yet
this is an extinct diving goose that was
found on the Channel Islands and up into
Central California
its bones have been found in the
Emeryville shell mound some other shell
mounds and it was flightless so it had
vestigial wings like one of the
Galapagos cormorants it could not fly
it's related to see ducks called scoters
and it was big it was the size of a
Canada Goose and paleontologists looking
at its skull think it had a very
heavy-duty bill and strong neck muscles
and douve under shallow water to wrench
off muscles and that was his entire life
it never flew it went extinct about
3,700 years ago and nobody knows why and
this is another mystery is it's a lot
easier to see the evidence but to see
the cause of that evidence is difficult
was it changing water temperatures due
to gradual climate changes or was it
over hunting by native
Americans nobody knows there are a lot
of interesting habitats in California
that I also wanted to research for the
book and I started with the grassland
which was a tough one to reconstruct but
that's where my house was I learned it
was the most of the Richmond Berkeley
Hills was a vast open grassland and I
get that question a lot too as people
wonder if there were a lot of trees that
have been cut down and that's why
everything is so open but when you read
the historical accounts of ships coming
in entering the bay for in the 1700s
1800s that's usually what they comment
on is how grassy everything was all
around the bay and then they could see
the redwoods
coming up above Oakland and a patch of
Oaks right where Oakland is there is
another patch of Oaks on the north face
of Angel Island and some of the canyons
had little oak Grove's but it was mostly
grassland including San Francisco full
of grasshoppers they say ground
squirrels and rabbits
here's Silicon Valley long ago in the
past and it's the hills were just open
grassland with this is a nodding wild
rye and bluegrass native bunch grasses
and San Jose was south of the bay were
just a series a maze of tidal channels
and marshes now this the manuscript for
this book was gigantic because I wanted
to cover everything and make it a huge
academic encyclopedia and the publisher
heyday said well we're gonna have to
trim this down they actually gave me 372
pages and 70 color illustrations and
then it took four years to get the
manuscript down to that the book that's
there they did a good job but they sent
all my manuscript off to a designer who
arranged everything as you see in the
book now and they sent right before
printing sent off to the printer they
sent me a PDF file emailed it to me and
said can you go through the whole 372
pages and catch any mistakes so I did
and I caught a lot of mistakes
Birds sketches were mislabeled but I
missed two things and probably only I
care about this most people wouldn't
care but one of them is that painting
shows California oat grass is a really
interesting native bunch grass my sister
has one planted in her backyard and it's
a strange native grass because the stems
grow horizontally along the ground and
you can see that in the photograph and I
drew a sketch of it with the stem along
the ground it might have been an
adaptation to elk stomping on it and
they couldn't get at the seeds
well the designer turned that horizont
or vertical and so you can see it's all
vertical along with all the other
grasses cuz that's how grasses should
grow and I just missed it but that's
okay here's an oil painting of a really
interesting type of habitat within our
vast and very native grasslands in
California this is a vernal pool and
this changed very quickly through the
year from in winter it was full of
rainwater and had a fairy shrimp and a
tadpole shrimp and frogs and salamanders
breeding in it and then in the spring
that would all dry up and there'd be
rings of wild flowers around these and
then in the summer special kinds of inch
or two and shy native grasses would grow
green in the center of these that are
endemic only to this type of habitat
only in California and here I imagine
pronghorn antelope coming to graze on
them so this is a rare habitat that
still exists but it was a lot more
common in the past some of these were
recorded were
the Oakland area is and the flatlands
and Berkeley here's an oil painting of
again my neighborhood in the past a
grassland looking west towards the
Golden Gate long ago now most of the
book is the last ten thousand years of
California history because and that's
called the Holocene which is been a
generally the climate has been more even
the animals that have existed here are a
certain the modern animals we see now
wolves
Grizzlies elk pronghorn but prior to ten
thousand years ago was the Ice Age and
for a million years two million years
beyond that was a very different kind of
California and I couldn't help a couple
of times in the book go back a little
further and enter this Ice Age world so
this is San Francisco Bay forty thousand
years ago and when they built the first
Bay Bridge they put the giant pilings
deep into the bay mud and they hit
bedrock but they also hit bones these
fossils of animals that lived before the
bay was a bay and when this was a big
Valley they hit the bones of an extinct
giant bison which was the Ice Age bison
that you see in the La Brea Tar Pits it
was huge
six feet at the shoulder and had much
larger horns than our modern bison and
extinct horses there are native horses
all over the San Francisco Bay in the
Ice Age and it was before the bay
because of course all these giant
glaciers that covered the northern
continents and the Ice Age locked up a
lot of sea water so the the actual ocean
shore was 50 miles out to where about
the Farallon Islands are now and San
Francisco was a valley this was not a
bay the bay
gradually entered through the golden
gate thousands of years later the oak
woodland is another very important
habitat all over California this is an
oil painting of aloni women pounding
acorns in bedrock mortars and it's based
on Berkeley mortar Rock Park which you
can still go and actually see these very
boulders with these exact mortars in
them and right now it's surrounded by
houses but Oaks had a cyclic ecology
that we may have disrupted at times now
this is a dense summer jungle of Valley
Oaks which was very common along the
rivers such as Sacramento San Joaquin
draped with curtains of California wild
grapes but in the winter before the age
of dams and levees all the snow melt
from the sear and the spring would
spread out over vast areas of the
Central Valley and flood the roots of
these valley Oaks and give them
nutrients there are some problems now
with the lack of Oaks reproducing and
some of it may be due to these
ecological changes that have happened or
we don't allow these valleys to flood
anymore and have huge inland seas but
that's precisely what led to all the
abundance and fertility of the Central
Valley soils this is I think this was a
cotton field that I took a picture of
after it had been turned and harvested
somewhere near Bakersfield and in the
past this area this is a particular spot
called the Cahuilla Oaks and it was lush
had huge towering valley Oaks and it had
a native grass called creeping wild rye
which was one of our few non bunch
grasses it was a rhizomatous grass a sod
grass that grew over acres and acres and
it was green in the
summer and when the first Europeans
entered this Cahuilla Oaks they said
well who who's been trimming all these
trees and mowing the grass it looks like
people have been managing this area it
looks like an English Park and in fact
people were managing this area for
thousands of years
another interesting oak habitat is now
under Hetch Hetchy Reservoir today with
the dam and in the past California black
Oaks ponderosa pines grew in this valley
similar to Yosemite Valley and all the
researches for this book though what I
found the most interesting more so than
the Grizzlies and these habitats was the
processes that caused this change over
10,000 years processes like fire flood
climate that we think we can control
sometimes but we may not be able to we
need to learn to live with them
like people in the past this is a
Chumash village and you can see that
there's a lot of evidence of fires in
the area there's some smoke on the hills
people for thousands of years we're
setting fires to almost every habitat in
California and I've heard a term called
firestick farming where instead of using
a plow you use a stick and set fire to
habitat to maintain it with fire and I
talked to some native elders who told me
well we burned everything the marshes
under the Oaks the chaparral the
grasslands and they had a very
complicated system of four grasslands it
might have been every year in a certain
area and oak woodlands it might have
been every five years I mean people were
just now are starting to discover how
complex a system this may have been for
thousands of years shaping the state
and then therefore there's a lot of
plants that are fire-adapted
in the chopper al especially there's two
kinds of plants that respond differently
to fires one is like manzanita doesn't
die but has a root underground and it
sprouts another kind the adult shrub
dies but it throws out a bunch of seeds
and the seeds grow really quickly and it
becomes a shrubland again so learning
how important fire is to the California
habitats and landscape I had to become
somewhat of a fire follower and go seek
out control burns and even places that
had been accidentally scarred with fire
and go see what happened
observe the land so this is a valley oak
woodland that I painted near this an
accidental burn along a highway but it
imitated perhaps a native burn because
it was a low intensity grass fire and
when I came back about two or three
weeks later the bottom painting I
thought well that looks bad
all the oaks looked dead this is a bad
scene but when I walked into the scene
all the blue Oaks had sprouted new green
leaves
they had just been singed they weren't
dead at all and there were actually some
native purple needle grass bunches that
even after two or three weeks were
growing new green leaves so the whole
landscape was coming back in less than a
month here's a painting in the Tehachapi
Mountains in Southern California and
this woman has burned over this hill so
hillslope
several months ago of gray pine interior
live oak and shrubs and she knows that
in several months she can come back
through and collect different things
that the fire has caused to grow because
after a fire some shrubs will grow very
straight new twigs and these are
excellent for making bad
skits and she also knows that fires will
attract elk which the hunters hunted
because elk enjoy dining on the new
green growth of grass right after a burn
and flood is another important process
that I discovered that happens all over
and we try to contain it but aren't
always successful
Sacramento got a huge flood in the 1850s
which drowned the whole city people were
rowing around the streets and boats the
rivers are seemed to be almost alive
this is a sketch of the Sacramento River
one particular segment showing how it
the bins will migrate over a hundred
years
so the bins will straighten out and move
in a hundred years isn't even that long
of a time to have such a change in the
bank and then this is a map showing
these inland seas that would form in the
Central Valley before the age of dams
and levees the snowmelt would create big
huge inland lakes one of the most famous
was Buena Vista lake in the San Joaquin
Valley
a huge Inland Sea where people had very
large tule boats larger than in this
painting snow geese flying around
abundant waterfowl elk and that's the
High Sierras snow in the background and
working as a biologist I learned there
are some birds that were having trouble
protecting right now and it's partly
because we think we can just manage the
bird but we have to actually look at
their entire landscape that they're
living in some of these birds like
southwestern willow flycatcher and
Hutton's Vireo are adapted to floods
they really like to nest in areas little
creeks with overgrown willow thickets
that regularly flood and have a rich
swampy undergrowth
and because of a lot of management
practices these are rare now here's San
Bernardino Valley today the Inland
Empire and what was it like in the past
here's the Santa Ana River with
cottonwoods willows and sycamores and it
regularly flooded out treating these
nice marshes with Russia's alkali
Sackett on grasses and these are king
birds pershing in a giant sunflower that
grew to be 15 feet tall a native
sunflower and this was thought to have
gone extinct in 1937 this los angeles
sunflower they called it but recently
and this story keeps changing when I
every time I talk to a botanist I get
the latest version so in the book it's
already outdated this they've thought
they rediscovered the Los Angeles giant
sunflower about ten or twelve years ago
right next to LA unbelievably nobody had
noticed this 15-foot flower growing
there and it's they they analyzed it got
really excited but then they realized it
was apparently a new species it was a
little bit different from the
collections that showed the old Los
Angeles sunflower so now it's a new type
of wildflower called the Newhall
sunflower as found in Newhall Ranch but
I still think that's amazing that a
15-foot tall plant right next to one of
the largest cities in America was just
discovered and in climate you could
probably write another whole book on
just climate because that is such a
complex subject but what I thought was
interesting in my research was I
couldn't always link cause and effect
and so that was an interesting part of
trying to reconstruct the climate in the
past and even trying to see what would
happen in the future by looking at the
past but it was it's pretty tough
there's some questions that stumped me
for example there's a researcher who
studied blue oaks in Tejon Ranch area
which is Southern California cute one of
the biggest ranches that has a giant
chunk of pretty pristine California and
he took drills and he drilled into these
living oak trees just to get tree ring
counts and he also could see the fire
scars and tried to date how many fires
swept through this woodland so the top
bar chart shows the number of trees each
year little baby trees that reached
maturity and it shows that around 1850s
suddenly a bunch of young trees grew
into giant oak trees and this basically
is showing that the oak woodland we see
today
grew up in the 1850s and we haven't
gotten a lot of Oaks growing into trees
since then now what caused this peak in
trees growing up to be adult trees from
saplings that's the part that is really
tricky to tease out because right at the
same time 1850s the bottom chart shows
how there is a little ice age in
California in the Sierra Nevada prior to
that time lasted 400 200 years and there
were growing glaciers in the Sierras and
then right about 1850 they stopped
growing and started retreating so this
shows ice levels and build-up suddenly
going into this decline and so you think
well maybe it was climate change that
triggered something in these trees but
the fire scar history that the
researcher found saw that there are
apparently natives native people were
burning this woodland regularly almost
yearly until about 1850 and then
suddenly no more fires because that's
when Tejon ranch became a ranch and the
new management style was no
we're gonna have a lot of grass so at
the 1850s fires were completely stopped
and I learned that fire actually will
kill a lot of the pests such as ground
squirrels that eat the acorns so perhaps
this lack of acorns and growing into
trees was due to know an abundance of
ground squirrels but at the same time
1850s that's when the big cattle herds
were brought in for the first time Tejon
ranch had large herds of cattle and
cattle like to eat acorns and browse on
saplings so there's a lot of possible
causes for the patterns we see in the
past and we can only keep gathering more
evidence some other interesting climate
phases that we've had are El Ninos where
warm water will often come up and go
pretty far north off the coast of
California and this will bring with it
southern tropical species like tuna and
for fishermen this is a boon having
these warm phases and it was interesting
I learned that the word tuna actually
originated in California there were tuna
clubs that were off of San Diego Santa
Barbara and LA and they caught a fish
called a Tony
that's the original spelling of it later
became tuna and these tuna clubs thrived
that city of Avalon and the Channel
Islands was their headquarters but then
the warm water phase left and so did the
tuna and a decline and sport fishing
happened but it's comes back once in a
while and we get tuna coming far up
almost to San Francisco there's some
other strange birds that might be
related to climate change that have been
recorded in the past this is a painting
of a white fronted magpie Jay and if
there any bird watchers in the audience
you're probably thinking this isn't in
the bird books but it was sighted
in California in the 1800s and it now
only lives in Costa Rica and a little
bit of southern Mexico but for some
reason it was and it was even recorded
in Oregon so in the 1800's did we there
was some sort of cooler climate or was
it wetter to bring these tropical birds
up and there's a pattern here it wasn't
just somebody mistaking one odd bird and
misidentifying it some of the early
ornithologist John Townsend who was a
famous pioneer ornithologist recorded
this strange woodpecker in the mountains
of Southern California it's called the
Imperial woodpecker the largest
woodpecker in the world it is related to
ivory-bill woodpeckers and today it's
completely retreated away from
California and only lives in central
Mexico and old-growth pine mountains so
why it was seen in our state two
centuries ago no one knows but even
stranger there was a naturalist who his
name was John Santos and he was an Army
medic but he was also a great naturalist
and he was stationed at Fort Tejon which
is along Highway five where it enters
the the grapevine pass and in 1857 he
was such a good pioneering scientist
that he recorded a lot of the animals
that lived in California and mailed his
specimens back to the Smithsonian and of
course he had a gun he didn't have a
camera so he would go around shooting
birds and animals and Grizzlies and
skinning them and shipping the skins
back to the Smithsonian this is the way
they did it back then but one day he
climbed up this tree to get to a hawks
nest and he looked into the hawks nest
that he found the head of a parrot a big
green parrot with a patch of red on it
and he he said oh well this is a bad
specimen I don't want to mail this back
so he said I'll shoot a whole one
another
time but he never saw another one and he
wrote a letter to the biologist back at
the Smithsonian he said you know I'm
really sorry I didn't collect that
parrot head because I've heard other
people talk about flocks of parrots
outside of San Diego and I've talked to
some people about this and they say well
it was just people had pet parrots and
they got away but this was 1857 and that
is possible but it is also possible that
a native thick-billed parrot or a
different species it was apparently a
large one was coming into California
because of some different climate or
different habitats that we don't have
today because of some change and some
ecological process so I have a theory
that it might have been thick-billed
parrots so I have a painting of those
living in California but it's still a
mystery so what can we do to maybe take
a little bit of this early California
and try to bring a little bit of it back
some people will come up to me and say
well you just want to get rid of all the
cities right and go back to this this
time and I tell them no I I enjoy our
culture and I really like California but
I think it would be really nice to bring
some of this back some of the healthy
old ecosystems and some of these
ecological processes in the past I think
it actually could be very important to
learn to live with fire and flood and
some of this climate change that people
have learned to live with thousands of
years ago this is just my sister over in
Richmond she's tried to restore that
same native grassland that used to live
on the hills in the East Bay in her
little tiny yard in the the suburb so
she has native wildflowers native bunch
grasses and it can be tricky because the
city of Richmond actually knocked on her
door and said you need to cut these
weeds
so he has a process of Education to try
to get the city to accept her little bit
of old California so I in conclusion I
can't resist going back to the Ice Ages
20,000 years ago to see how different
California has changed we think that
California is you look at the land and
it's always been that way but it's
always changing and the farther you go
back in time sometimes it's
unrecognizable this is a scene that was
all over the Bay Area in the Ice Age
giant Columbian mammoth
roaming about packs of saber-tooth cats
sometimes going after their the baby
mammoths and the largest North American
mammalian land predator ever to live the
giant short-faced bear it was six feet
at the shoulder and designed to run so
it may have looked much fiercer and made
the grizzly appear tame so and thank you
for coming and I hope you enjoyed my
glimpse of early California
let's go have a seat see it right here
well of course Paul somebody is a
question any predictions for what
California will look like in the next
100 1000 and 10,000 years yeah that's
always that's the trickiest question
because I've really studied the past a
lot and then to try to apply that to the
future I just think it's that's a tough
proposition so what I try to do is say
well look at those ecological processes
I was talking about like fire and flood
and the climate change and try to apply
those to the future like we're not going
to be able to totally control what
California landscapes will look like but
we can try to guide some of those
ecological processes into the future to
keep our habitats healthy so if you take
a piece of land you're not going to be
able to restore it to exactly how it was
in the past and you're not going to be
able to exactly control what species are
there 200 years from now but if you can
help it along by say doing some control
burns or letting the creeks flood it
once in a while that can help it take
care of itself you might actually guide
that piece of land to a healthier future
so I try to look at it in a more
abstract fashion what's interesting this
is the first I've heard of a kind of a
go with it sense about climate change
even though humans are engaged in in
pushing it nevertheless climate shifted
altering the time that you look ice ages
and stuff like that
so there's a kind of an accommodationist
view that emerges from this well yeah
the stuff comes and goes and sea level
rises and falls go with it is that your
view by this time I definitely think we
can be more sustainable as we are now
but I'm not a believer that we can
control
nature so I am of the thought that
adapting to the change that may come in
whatever form is a really healthy thing
to learn I mean I'm not against trying
to lower carbon emissions I think we
should definitely be doing that go with
renewable energy but I am also a
believer in these processes can't always
be completely controlled as I've learned
in the past so Oh learning to live with
them is also really important I think
you know there's a I realize a period
missing so I say just up to twelve
thousand ten thousand years ago and then
it gets warm and the water comes in and
fills the bay but also we got humans
around at that point and they're killing
megafauna the ones that don't kill them
and burning and so in a sense we never
saw a post Ice Age non-human environment
in California that's true yeah and I
wonder if there's anything like between
the ice ages because there are nine big
ones and then spaces between do you get
any sense of what it was like between
the ice ages before humans showed up you
know there's kind of an interesting
story I learned about back to the
grasslands and there seem to be two
phases of the history of our native
grasslands and they learned this from
the soil looking at the soil so in the
Ice Age you had less grass and more
megafauna these mammoths and bison and
horses and they know that because they
found the spores of a specific type of
fungi that only lives and dung
it's a dung fungus and it needs huge
amounts of this on the order of an
African savannah with herds of animals
this disappears about ten to eleven
thousand years ago and is replaced in
the soil with charcoal so the this our
California went from a huge grazing
African savanna type ecosystem to be the
animals went extinct the big megafauna
and it was replaced with apparently
Native American burning fire took over
is the controlling factor so I don't
think there was a time when you did you
you didn't have an in-between time we
never knew what grasslands were like not
impacted by some big process of change
another relic that I wonder about is the
pronghorn antelope that you have
beautiful pictures of they're really
fast they're faster than short-faced
bear there faster than Jaguars I suspect
was there a cheetah here that was as
fast as they were and that's why they're
still so speedy yeah that's an
interesting point just the why do you
have this one of the fastest land
animals ever the pronghorn antelope -
there they go they're said to run like
70 miles per hour in short bursts and
can sustain 50 miles per hour for an
hour so why and coyotes can't run that
fast wolves are not that fast so why why
do we have this animal that can run that
fast well there was a native cheetah in
the Ice Age there's a North American
cheetah that might have been something
that pushed the evolution of antelopes
and it's now extinct and we just are
left with fast antelopes it's
interesting you would expect the
evolution to sort of give them let them
cool out there's a lot of missing niches
out there missing like gaps I think well
we bring the cheetah back that'll be
interesting along with the grizzly what
the hell those horses you did not draw
those versus 10 or 20,000 40,000 field
sketches you drawing with stripes and
stripes on the front so from you know
front view it's a zebra from their rear
view it's something else you make that
up or how did you get that yeah I
obviously made it up but there's um
when paleontologists look at really
closely at the horse anatomy of these
fossil horses there were true horses
there were donkeys zebras a whole bunch
of strange extinct types of horses that
have some characters of a true horse and
some characters of a zebra for instance
there was in South Africa has anyone
heard of the quagga it was a zebra like
animal that had only stripes on the back
and looks like a horse in front so
looking at this the bones of this
ancient California horse which is in the
La Brea Tar Pits its fossils it appeared
to be somewhat like this quagga and its
anatomy half striped and half not so the
rest is imagination how big was this
animal it was the size of a regular
horse it was a pretty yeah bring it back
couple questions one from Tristan bout
grasses here one reads I've heard the
grasses around the bay area used to be
green all year round for European
grasses were introduced is that true and
Alexander McCormick says what about the
grasses of the Golden Hills that we see
everywhere is that native yeah it's been
a lot of time trying to find native
grasses all over California so I got a
pretty good idea of actually looking at
the grass is growing on the hills that
if they were burned they these bunch
grasses would be green into the summer
and if they weren't cuz patches wouldn't
be burned they had beautiful gold and
tall stalks and so I think we had Golden
Hills even a thousand years ago but we
also had some areas that would be quite
green from all the native burning so
Kevin Kelly asks are there any
experiments now of doing burning of the
grasslands in a yearly way or in a way
even as complex as the Indians Houston
oh yeah there's
all over where people are studying this
there's like I think Stanford has a lot
of research areas that have oaks and
grass and they are doing control burns
to see how native app in Chester Ridge
or where Hastings interests oh so you
know national parks are taking this to
Yosemite National Park has a whole
program of burn control burning under
the forests to try to mimic this ancient
pattern of native burning bring health
back to the ecosystem so natives and
aliens to be a few questions on these
personally I'm a native plant Nazi and
bio bigot is we're called so lily asked
what extent do you consider invasive
species to be a threat and Mary Michalak
SAR McAllister asks a native plant
advocates in San Francisco seem to
believe they'll be replaceable to
replace all our non-native trees with
native trees based on your knowledge do
you think that's possible I don't think
well it all take grasslands because I've
really studied that and I we're never
gonna get rid of all the European annual
grasses such as wild oats cheatgrass all
the brown grasses they're here to stay
and that may be true for trees too and I
have two opinions on that because I
sometimes just really would like to see
nothing but natives I can be an unreal
native like a fan yeah but it on the
other hand being practical I I think
it's really interesting how all plants
have a use and all plants have some
interesting characters that you can
collect native collect seeds from some
of the introduced grasses and trees
sometimes they're good wild wild bird
food so I'm kind of of two minds of that
but I don't think we're ever gonna
eradicate all invasive plants and so
there's another thing in the future that
we can maybe adapt to them somehow well
okay the eucalyptus much-loved
much-hated
I love them by moonlight and with a wind
blowing for
and I guess a question in my mind is as
long as I've been in California
he's very prominent the ecliptic trees
mostly blue gums are you know defining
the the landscape and and the nature the
undergrowth and all that sort of thing
how long before they get their green
card good question I mean is it a
thousand years 200 years were almost up
on probably 200 from some of the early
ones that came here ceremony yeah
welcome eucalyptus haha so John Gill
morass went the Berkeley Hills covered
with redwoods in 1900 and then they were
logged in 1906 Oh 8 to rebuild San
Francisco is this the case and how long
had they been there yes the part of the
Oakland Berkeley Hills had a redwood
forest and then north of that was all
grassland and south of that was grassy
ridges there's some paintings you can
see grassy ridges and then right above
Oakland these tall redwoods that were
used by sailors as navigation beacons
because they were just gigantic and
they've been there since the Ice Age I
mean redwoods are an ancient go back
hundred mil to tens of millions of years
into the age of dinosaurs
so redwoods have been in California for
millions of years and that particular
grove has probably been there for maybe
10 20 thousand years but it's
interesting I've talked to a botanist
who has looked at some of the old
evidence of stumps and he thinks some of
those redwoods were taller than the
redwoods in Redwood National Park
meaning they were the tallest in the
world right outside of Oakland and they
were all logged and its second growth
now but there might be some stumps out
there that show evidence of just
monstrous redwood trees there's a long
term project to regrow
redwoods of the Oakland Hills to be the
tallest redwoods in the world again
that's a thousand years yeah you know
bear down people question from Julia do
you have to extend this project to other
regions
thirty years per state times well I now
live in the desert Mojave Desert of
Nevada
I'm not even a Californian so I'd like
to do the Southern California desert
sand Nevada Great Basin that's my next
project and you're now collecting that
data and painting or what and what do
you find well we're very interested is
the long now foundation because we're
aiming to build a ten thousand year
clock in Eastern Nevada over in Spring
Valley where do I guess you've been so
what's the sort of general picture of
the last ten twenty thousand years in
Nevada what's been going on there was
energy because it's not of course a lot
of cities that you have to reconstruct
but there have been vast times of epic
drought where things were quite dry
thousands of years ago and then there
were times of great lushness and lakes
water areas so it's a little more subtle
than parts of California that have had
so much building and development you've
probably spent time up around Pyramid
Lake which is sort of a relic of the of
the ancient huge lakes that were in that
area
what do you pretty much the lake if it's
just this it's not small but it's small
compared to what used to be there with
moss Mastodon bones sticking out of the
silt as I remember in Burning Man going
up on top of the silver so and deep I
mean I was told that silt is like
thousands of feet deep in parts it was
like the Black Rock Desert so when you
go back what was Nevada like when it was
those Lakes
that's an amazing yeah.the those were
ice age lakes that were huge I mean they
were the size of you know the whole Salt
Lake Basin near Salt Lake City that was
all covered with an enormous inland
see and in parts of Nevada all
interconnected huge diverse fish faunas
and I just learned that the last
mammoths Colombian mammoths were found
right around that Pyramid Lake so in
other words that that habitat was their
favorite habitat about ten eight
thousand years ago they had gone extinct
all over North America except that part
of Nevada and then they that was their
last stand so there's something the ice
age remained there longer than anywhere
else in the continent let's suggest that
Nevada in a way has greater extremes
maybe because of the rain shadow of the
Sierra Nevada and so California is
what's somewhat modulated by being next
to the ocean yeah we have this beautiful
Mediterranean climate with it almost
imitates California west of the seers is
more like 40 million years ago when we
had the tertiary period and it was a
little subtropical and Nevada is more
like the Ice Age with extreme cold and
winds and intense temperature changes so
you know we're pretty lucky here it's a
mild climate so it sounds to me that if
the temperature keeps going up because
of anthropogenic climate change or
whatever reasons getting warmer the tuna
are coming back
California's redwoods I guess will be
okay because it's moderated somewhat by
this Mediterranean climate but Nevada is
gonna be all over the map with climate
change is that what it looks like from
your standpoint you know I keep trying
to research models of what says the
deserts in Nevada are gonna look like if
we have a warming climate and some areas
will get Rainier because it might the
the rising sea surface temperature in
the Gulf might produce more of a monsoon
and produce more summer rain in other
areas will get drier so it's it's tricky
to you know pin it down it could be
complex
now you mentioned a little earlier you
like renewable energy but I get a sense
from
websites that you're not terribly fond
of solar farms out in the desert at
least well see a little more about that
well you know having moved to the desert
and studying these long term changes in
these beautiful desert valleys I
discovered there's sort of a a good
solar energy and a not-so-good type of
solar energy and one of the good type is
where you plaster all the roofs in a
city with solar panels and hook it
directly to the grid and it's used right
locally where you generate the energy
and this is fantastic to me but there's
another kind which I kind of called the
industrial model of solar where they
take a valley full of desert tortoises
and yuccas and Joshua trees and they
have to grade seven square miles flat
and move all the tortoises to put these
solar panels which they could put on
roofs so that's that's a there's sort of
a controversy there about we definitely
need renewable energy as soon as we can
but there's sort of a good way to do it
and maybe a less good way to do it
there must be different sites I mean the
the thing you get in Nevada is a bit of
everything so there's the sagebrush
ocean of the the great basins that are
pretty green
you got the Mojave I know where you are
or much of it is pretty green you also
have these salt flats that are really
mineral is it okay to put solar there
you know that's a nurse you know I
actually asked the solar companies could
you move it off this green lush desert
on to the the flat and they said well
that floods in the winter all the
rainwater comes and you don't want to
have your electric cables between the
panel's flooded with water so that
apparently that's not technically a good
place now there are places I don't
believe that for a minute that's
ridiculous it's not like it's not deep
water you know this is not like this
offshore or something I think that
should there should be a pilot study of
can you do it in a floodable salt flap
which is why not won't care right
but there is a good place that's been
suggested the Westlands water district
in the San Joaquin Valley that got cut
off from its Delta water all those
dyeing almond orchards that land is
doesn't flood and it's degraded farmland
so degraded with selenium salts because
they were these ancient Ice Age Lake
deposits have been sort of leeching up
through the soil and ruining this
farmland plus there's not enough water
plus there's giant transmission lines
going here that have open capacity so
we've been sort of advocating will put
these very large solar power plants
right there
who's we I have a group called Basin and
Range watch that tries to advocate for
sustainable use of our deserts so this
is Basin and Range Watch developing a
map of sites that you would consider
okay for big solar farms we don't even
need to there's a PA house what's called
a repower America website and they have
something like millions of acres of
degraded lands like old mine sites
Superfund sites that you could put solar
panels on so our work has been done for
us how about when do you like winter is
that a problem in Nevada wind can be bad
in some ways if you have big industrial
wind turbines right next to bat caves
such as in Spring Valley they built this
about two miles from oh the rose guano
bat cave which has a million Mexican
free-tailed bats that roost in this cave
and wind is so new in large quantities
that they're they have what they're
gonna do with this wind farm the company
will have a little radar installation
that will try to detect the bat mass of
bats and they're actually saying they're
gonna turn the windmills off and so that
will see oh do you guys leave they're
watching yes see how many dead bats this
old we that this this bat cave she's
speaking of is in the area where we
aimed
clock in Nevada so people go visit the
clock we'll go visit the Batcave and
they'll help you keep track of their
training when Chargers off we also
expect boom by the way that a 10,000
year clock is not going to see 10,000
years of wind turbines and North Spring
Valley if this is something that will
come and then go and be replaced by the
fusion or who knows what and what's fun
is you are setting in motion people
paying attention to these kind of
changes and this kind of life set of
life forms in the large scale over
thousands of years
we just think that's wonderful thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you